all right we are on problem number 10
problem number 10. and this says on the
first you see 10 my absolute value of 10
minus k is equal to 3
and that we know that the absolute value
of k minus
is equal to 8.
and they say what is the value of k that
satisfies both equations above
let's do the first one the absolute
value of 10 minus k is equal to 3 that
tells us that 10
minus k is equal to 3 or
minus k is equal to minus 3 right
so what happens what if 10 minus k is 3
so k just based on the first equation
alone i get k is equal to 7 right 10
minus 7 is equal to 3 and here k is
equal to 13.
so just on this first constraint we have
k is equal to 7 or 13.
so now let's do the second constraint
i'll do it in yellow
so k minus 5 is 8 so k minus five
this that absolute value is equal to
eight so it's either k minus five is
equal to eight or k minus five is equal
to minus eight right
k minus five is eight then k is 13.
if k minus 5 is equal to minus 8 then
that means k
is equal to minus 3.
in order for k to satisfy both of this
equations
well
but i've just kind of solved it
what k satisfies both these equations
well 7 only satisfies the first one and
negative 3 only satisfies the second one
but 13 k equals 13 satisfies both
so that is
your answer
13. next problem
number 11 got to do some drawing
image clear image invert colors
i'm going to go for a walk after this i
need to
work off that turkey all right so let's
see i have a
line here
like that that's line m
i have line
l
something like that and then i have this
perpendicular line
up here like that
and then what do they tell us they tell
us that this is perpendicular
to such colors they tell us that this is
65 degrees
they tell us
that this right here
is x degrees
oh and there's another line there i
haven't even drawn it
there's another line that i haven't
drawn
that is this
switching back to the green
so this is 20 oh whoops
this is 20 degrees
and so this is x x is only just
x is just this thing right here
not this whole thing and this is 20
degrees
okay what do they want us figure out
what is the value of x in the figure
above
all right so we just gotta do what what
i like to
affectionately call the angle game
so what is and the angle game i just try
to figure out as many angles as i can
figure out so what is what is the
measure of this angle
well this angle and this angle are
complementary they add up to 90 degrees
right because we know this is 90. so
this whole thing is 90.
so
if this and this add up to 90 what is
this well x plus 9 well now i should use
x well this is going to be 25 right i
don't know 35 degrees
no no 25 right 25 degrees 25 plus 65 is
90 correct yes as you can tell
addition is my weak point so this is 25
degrees
this is 20 degrees can we figure out x
well sure
we know that all these three angles
combined have to add up to 180 now right
because they're all kind of collectively
supplementary they all you go around you
go halfway around the circle so we know
that x
plus 20 plus 25 is equal to 180
x plus 45 is equal to 180.
so x is equal to 1 this is the problem
that's where i always mess up so it was
40 would be one for x is equal to 1 35
so that's our that's our answer
next problem
clear image
invert colors
all right
so let's see
so number 12.
that last problem was one that my cousin
had marked up pretty incorrectly so
i had to take some pauses to make sure i
i didn't mark it up incorrectly okay
problem number 12 the median of a set
the median of a set of nine
consecutive integers is 42.
what is the greatest of these integers
so the median of nine consecutive
integers is 42.
so 42 is the middle number
right
so and there's nine consecutive numbers
so 42 is the middle number and they're
nine consecutive how many numbers are
going to be greater than 42 middle
median means middle right so that means
there are five numbers greater
five greater
and there are five
what am i doing that means there are
four greater
and four
less
right because there's a total of nine
numbers four less 42 and then four
greater right and they're consecutive
numbers so what are the going to be the
four numbers greater than it well 43 44
45 46. the question asks us what is the
greatest of the numbers well it's sure
it's going to be 46.
and you could have written out all the
numbers but you know 42 is the middle
they're four greater and four less you
just do 4 saves a little time
problem number 13
let the function f be defined by
f of x
is equal to
x
plus one
if two f of p is equal to twenty so two
times f of p
is equal to 20.
what is the value of f
of 3p this looks fun
so 2 times f of p is equal to 20 what is
f of 3p
so let's evaluate 2 times f of p
so it's two
times f of p
well that equals two times and you put p
into this equation two times p plus one
right we know that equals twenty
and so you know that two p
plus two i just distributed the two is
equal to twenty
two p is equal to eighteen
p is equal to nine
right
we just solve for p and this is just you
know they're they're trying to confuse
you with notation there's nothing really
that fancy here it's a very simple
equation to solve
and once you know p equals 9 then we say
well f of
3p that's the same thing because p
equals 9 of f of 27
and now this becomes just a simple
function evaluation f of 27 is equal to
27 plus 1
27 plus 1 27 plus 1 is just
that's it
next problem problem number 14.
problem 14 i'll do in green
problem number 14. i have to do some
drawing now
all right i'll do it big because it
looks complicated
big line there
i have
a line here that's almost
horizontal
and then
this is looks like it's perpendicular it
is
okay like that and then i'll go like
that
there and then i have another
perpendicular line like that
all right that's that's a nice looking
drawing
okay so then
this is
j
k
l
n
m they tell us that this is 90 degrees
is perpendicular this is x
degrees
they also tell us that this is 125
they also tell us that this is
perpendicular
in the figure above
k n
k n is perpendicular to j l okay we knew
that because they drew it and l m
l m is perpendicular to j l yeah we knew
that because they drew that there if the
lengths of l n
so the lengths of l
n
l n and l m are equal
l n
and l m are equal these are equal
lengths
what is the value of x
well if we know that these two sides are
equal what do we also know about its
base angles oh sure that this angle
is going to have to be equal to this
angle right
so that angle is equal to that angle
let's figure out what that is if this
this purple angle here is 125 what is
this well they're supplementary
so they add up to 180. so this is 125. i
just realized i only have 35 seconds
left to do this problem but actually
i'll continue it in the next video
because i only have 20 seconds now to do
this so i'll see you in the next video